welcome everyone to today's meeting of
the cabinet
both those that are participating and to
those who are watching on the live
stream
if members have technical difficulties
during the meeting then please contact
the democratic services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you on call
today is james clapson
his number is 577-2000
this will also be at the top of the chat
thread for members if you need it
for those of you who are watching via
the council's youtube stream
please follow the instructions below the
video if there are any issues with the
live feed
i would ask participants when you are
not speaking to please mute your
microphone
this minimizes background noise and will
help everyone in listening to the
proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate on the chat to the
right side of the screen
and i will then make a note and go back
to you once the person speaking has
finished
please note that we will be following
the usual cabinet protocols
in which other members of the council
usually speak only once on each item
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned
silent and they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
and ensure that you are in a quiet room
free from distractions for the duration
of the meeting
please also note that this meeting is
being live streamed for members of the
public
the meeting will also be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet
please can i ask the members of the
cabinet to confirm that they are present
in the meeting when i read out your name
i will ask for the attendance of those
counsellors who are participating in
order to speak
under council procedure rule 20.1
separately
councillor alvin present
councillor duckworth present
and councillor yates president
do we have any members who would like to
speak under council procedure
rule 20.1
apologies have been received from
councillor everett
um as far as i'm aware we have no more
apologies for absence
does anyone have an interest to declare
in the items of business on the agenda
this evening
okay so we'll move to the minutes of the
previous meeting
we are now moving to approve the summary
of recommendations and decisions of the
cabinet meeting held on the 17th of
december 2020
copy being attached to the agenda pack
please may i have a proposer and a
seconder
happy to propose yeah and i'll second
yeah
and thank you councillor albin unless
there is any objection i will take these
as approved
and now we move on to the main business
of the meeting
um and i would like to introduce
councillor yates
um for what i'm sure will be an
exceptional breakdown
of our budget monitoring report number
three 2020 through to 2021
thank you very much councillor yates i
pass over to you
thank you jeff this report is the third
budget monitoring report for this year
the gross general fund overspend of 5.2
million pounds is largely due to covered
and is similar to the previous
monitoring report
government financial support is
estimated at 3.5 million pounds
giving a net over overspend forecast of
1.7 million pounds
the report also highlights and seeks
approval for expenditure in relation to
covid and eu transition
all this expenditure will be covered by
specific government funding pots
both the general fund and housing
revenue account capital programmes are
showing a substantial underspend
this again is largely due to covert as
works contracts have been hampered
and suppliers have been unable to
deliver within normal time frames
it is planned for most capital projects
to catch up during the next financial
year
i moved the recommendations
do i have a proposal
uh the chair councillor should just
propose
do i have a second i'll check her next
year thank you very much cancer alban
and in that case we now move on to item
five which is our medium term financial
strategy
2021 through to 25 and i pass again to
councillor yates
thank you very much thank you jim this
report provides analysis commentary on
the macroeconomic position
and specifically the impact of covert 19
it sets out the prospect of radical
local government finance reform
which will have an impact on our on our
major sources of funding from government
this reform is planned during 2021 for
implementation from 2022 to 2023
the financial projections in this report
come with a health warning
they are based on the best guess of our
finance staff at the government reforms
discuss discussions of which have not
yet begun
but they anticipate a reduction in
income largely through a rebasing of
business rates
dampened to some extent from the
tapering of the introduction of the
changes
apart from government funding there are
inflationary pressures of over
eight hundred thousand pounds each year
which cannot be covered by increases in
council tax and fees and charges alone
table three in paragraph 7.1 sets out
the overall picture
it projects a budget gap of 1.7 million
pounds in 2022 to 2023
and another 700 000 pounds in 2023
2024 i would emphasize again that these
figures are rough projections
and i know i speak for the section 151
officer and giving this caveat
but it is clear that we all need to
start rethinking how we deliver services
over the medium term
some potential solutions are included in
sections nine and
sections then the housing revenue
account is under similar inflationary
pressures as a general fund
four-year projections are included in
the sections of the eleven and they show
annual hra deficits
although the hra is projected to turn
surplus in future years
and move the recommendations
thank you very much for that councillor
yates um so cabinet's being asked to
approve the medium-term financial
strategy
2021 through to 25. unless there is any
objection i will take this
as approved and ask for a seconder for
the motion
yeah i'll check a net here thank you um
i've just been advised that in my
brilliant first time sharing
um i failed to approve the um
section four so um if i would like to
briefly
move back to that cabinet is us being
asked to approve
the recommendations for item four
are there any objections to the approval
of item four
no and again i believe we had councillor
alban as a seconder
and so i'll move on to item six
and many apologies for that
um item five
medium term financial strategy
no we've done five item six council tax
base calculation
2021 through to 22 and i introduced
councillor yates again
thank you chair this report presents for
approval to council the council tax base
for 2021 to 2022
which has decreased by 0.88 on the
on the previous financial year the
report proposes that from the 1st of
april 2021 the council will charge a 300
premium
on properties that have been empty and
substantially unfurnished for more than
10 years
this is the maximum premium that can be
charged and its introduction will help
get many empty
properties back into occupancy the
report also recommends to maintain the
existing council tax support scheme
i move the recommendations
thank you councillor yates so to recap
cabinet is recommended to
approve the district's council tax base
for 201.2122
as 44 155.70
and the tax base for the towns and
parishes in the council's administrative
area are set out in the table at annex 2
to the report
confirm the introduction of a council
tax premium for all properties that have
been left empty and substantially
unfurnished for 10 years or more
this will take effect from the first of
april 2021
and will introduce the premium of 300
and determine not to revise the council
tax reduction scheme for 2021-22
unless i hear any objection i will take
these as approved
and ask for a second yeah i'll check in
that chair thank you
thank you very much councillor alban
item 7
budget 2021-22 and again i passed to
councillor yates
thank you chair this budget has been set
during a truly unprecedented
period for local government councils
across the land are having to continue
to support residents and businesses in
exceptional ways
the government has produced substantial
funding to assist with covid test and
trace
enforcement and business grants as well
as eu transition
but it has placed a tremendous strain on
our workforce which itself has been
diminished by covert
has also placed a strain on local
government finances and than it is no
exception
not all covert losses have been
compensated and there continues to be
pressures on our budgets
expenditure is higher to compensate
residents and businesses and to protect
people through enforcement
and temporary housing income is lower in
respect to our fees and charges as well
as council tax
and business rates the current national
lockdown only adds to this pressure
it is very difficult to assess the
impact of covert and brexit on next
year's budget
there should be a reduction in covered
infection rates nationally and locally
once the vaccines are rolled out
and the worst local effects of brexit
the impact of manson being used as
the library park and latterly as a
testing station
should be passing but there will remain
the national local economic impact
some businesses will not have survived
or have built up debt
many people would have lost their jobs
it is unlikely that than it will bounce
back to its pre-pre-covered state
at least in the short term despite all
this
we have found it and not as worse off as
some other councils
whilst our reserves are relatively low
before covered we had built up a degree
of resilience
we had not chosen to invest in
commercial ventures which are typically
dependent on commercial rents
our reserves had slowly grown over the
previous five years and our balance
sheet showed that we are reducing our
overall borrowing
those authorities that we're not in a
similar position for covid are facing
much larger budget gaps than our 840 000
pounds
nonetheless the budget that i am
recommending the cabinet submits to
council does require savings our
priorities when considering these
savings were to minimize the impact on
services
and to minimize redundancies i'm pleased
to be able to report that there is
indeed a minimal impact on services
especially frontline services there are
up to eight posts
that will be deleted and the people
occupying those posts will be going
through restructuring
although it is too early to say some of
those
might be subject to compulsory
redundancy but every effort will be made
to find alternative council employment
for them
another objective the cabinet was to
adopt a transparent approach to setting
the budget
we authorized 10 budget briefings for
small groups and members
as well as two all-member briefings
there have been regular sessions with
shadow cabinet
while i know that each member in each
political group will be entitled to
challenge a budget of council
and vote according to their will i hope
this transparency at least means that no
one can say that they haven't had the
opportunity to partake in debate
the proposed increase in council tax at
four pounds 99
represents an increase of less than 10
pence a week for each household
on the hra we have acted to address the
legacy of poor management by east kent
housing
we successfully bought the service
in-house and we have a substantial
investment
plan in the hra capital programme we
acutely aware that government's housing
rent policy stipulates an increase of
cpi
plus one percent which represents a 1.5
rent increase for our tenants the
majority of this will be covered by
benefit or universal credit
but to help ease the burden on those of
our tenants not in receipt to benefit
we have elected to freeze affordable
rents this year
i would draw members attention to a
small error in paragraph 13.6.1
the average rent in 2021 to 2022 is set
to be one pounds 98 pounds
pence higher than the average rent in
2020 to 21.
not one pound 89 pence as stated in the
report
i move that the council approves the
recommendations
thank you very much counselling yates so
to recap
cabinet recommends to council that
the general fund revenue budget
estimates for 2021
22 were approved assuming a four pound
99 pence increase in the band equivalent
for council tax
that the hra budget estimates for
2021-22 were approved
assuming a cpi plus one increase in
social rents
and of reason affordable rents that the
general fund and housing revenue account
capital programs for 2021 through to 25
are approved that the flexible use of
capital receipt strategy
for 2021 to 22 is approved
and that section 151 officers assurance
statement is noted
unless i hear any objection i will take
these recommendations as approved for
submission to council
i'm seeing nothing in the chat at this
point so i would like to ask
excuse me chairman councillor uh i would
second that
proposal chair thank you very much
cancer alvin
and now we move on to item eight
which is our treasury management
strategy statement
minimum revenue provision policy
statement an annual investment strategy
for 2021 through to 22
and i pass over again to councillor
yates
thank you chair this report is required
in accordance with the sitfer
code of practice on treasury management
it covers the council's capital spending
and financial
plans and its treasury strategy backed
by potential indicators and limits the
2021
to 2022 to 2023 to 2024
inclusive the report also presents for
approval the council's minimum revenue
provision policy
capital strategy investment strategy and
non-treasury
investments report for 2021-2022
this report was considered by governance
and audit committee on the 25th of
november 2020
a move the cabinet approves the
recommendations
thank you very much councilli yates so
the recommendations are
that cabinet makes comments on this
report and annexes is appropriate
recommends this report on annexes
including each of the key elements
listed below to cancel for approval
including the capital plans prudential
indicators and the limits for 2021
22 to 20 23 24
including the authorized limit
prudential indicator
the minimum revenue provision mrp policy
the treasury management strategy for
2021 22
to 20 23 24 and the treasury indicators
the investment strategy for 2021-22
contained in the treasury
the management strategy including the
detailed criteria
the capital strategy for 2021-22
the non-treasury investments report for
21 and 22.
unless i hear any objection i will take
it these recommendations have been
approved
there's nothing in the chat as yet so i
would like to ask for a second
yes i'll check a next year sorry
thank you very much cancer alban um and
i believe that that concludes the
business for tonight's meeting
um i declare this meeting closed at 5 47
and i would like to say a huge thank you
to councillor yates and all officers
involved and thank you to everyone who
participated
and to those watching from home the live
stream of this